we're here in the florida keys and we've
come across a flesh-eating manatee
check this out look there's a man oh hey
manatee that's our buddy steve hi steve
he uh
he now eats lionfish carcasses it's a
flesh-eating manatee
oh that's so hardcore steve oh and
there's a
nurse shark right there so they all know
our boat they're ready for their dinner
hold on look at that oh there he goes
there he goes oh he just ate he just ate
it
that manatee just ate fish flesh so
he'll eat it spines at all
like um you know they kind of it just
seems like they kind of chew on i don't
know if they're getting like the
moisture out of the fish or what they
are but
they seem to play with it for quite a
while nice and tight
okay all right now drop it right right
in front of steve
lusting manatee oh he's just
totally sucking that down manatees
eating a venomous lionfish spines and
all that's crazy
steve you're my favorite manatee ever
man he's a pretty cool guy
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching